indeed in the early Decades of the 1700s
we see what can only be described as a
kind of epidemic of vampirism with a
whole host of famous and documented
claimed cases one of the most famous
early examples take place in Serbia in
1725 where a man named Peter plovi has
died and after having been in the grave
for 10 weeks reportedly had risen from
the
dead over the course of8 days nine
people m seriously died most of them
after being sick for only about 24
hours the victims claimed that it was
Peter plich that had visited them during
the night strangled them and sucked
their
blood as a result of this locals and two
public officials decided to exume his
body they reported that the corpse was
in very strange condition it gave off no
smell which is normal of a dead body of
course and the body in general was
surprisingly fresh